Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Tja, vielen Dank aber trotzdem für den Anruf.
Eines möchte ich noch sagen, also grundsätzlich bin ich ja der Wikipedia sehr dankbar. Ich bin ja in gewissen Gräsen als der Österreicher, der alles weiß, verstrien. Und ja, diesen Ruf habe ich der Wikipedia zu verdanken.
Na dann, viel Spaß damit und nicht beim Kneipen-Quiz bescheißen oder was, wo auch immer du das einsetzt. Dein Allwissen. Aber noch mal zu dem Artikel zurück. Wir haben jetzt klar gemacht, ok, der Andreas hat das irgendwie selber sozusagen recherchiert und naja, wenn jetzt jemand anzeifelt, was da passiert ist, dann kommt das einfach raus. Gibt es denn für mich als benutzende Möglichkeit, wenn ich weiß, ok, es gab da mal diesen Artikel, da ist jetzt was raus verschwunden, den verschwundenen Teil zu sehen?
Na ja, du brauchst nur einen Admin zu fragen, also beispielsweise mich auf der Diskussionsseite und sagen hier der Artikel, der wurde gelöscht, schick mir den doch mal bitte zu. Dazu musst du allerdings angemeldet sein, dass ich ihn dir per E-Mail zuschicken kann oder du gibst mir halt einfach deine Mail auf der Benutzersite. Das haben wir aber nicht so gern, dass Leute persönliche Daten veröffentlichen. Also anmelden, mir eine Mail per Wikimail schicken oder auch einfach so fragen und dann stelle ich ihn in meinen Benutzernahmenraum kurz her, die Leute können sich den rauskopieren und dann wird er wieder gelöscht.
Ok, aber du sagst, es gibt keinen, zeige mir gelöscht Artikel an.
Nein.
Aber warum eigentlich nicht?
Es gibt ein paar Tools dafür, die gibt es schon, wie viel gelöscht worden sind und du...
Ich meine aber, warum? Das ist ja eine prinzipielle Frage.
Es werden täglich ein paar hundert Sachen gelöscht.
Na ja, bloß zumindest dark, also ich meine mal die Mühlhalde, warum ist die nicht öffentlich?
Es gibt ja die Deletionpedia, die gibt es leider noch nicht auf Deutsch und hier der Aufruf an alle Leute, die sich wirklich für die Wikipedia interessieren, macht eine deutsche Deletionpedia und holt alles rein, was von der Löschung bedroht ist und bleibt das Wissen erhalten.
Aber du sagtest ja selber auch, dass die Inhalte nicht wirklich gelöscht werden, sondern einfach nur sozusagen versteckt sind. Warum schafft man dann keine Möglichkeit, die anzeigen zu lassen?
Ich wüsste jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht, was es da für einen Grund geben sollte.
Ja genau, den, den wir gerade die ganze Zeit diskutieren, das ist halt noch ein Fantasie.
Na ja, größtenteils sind die gelöschten Sachen ja wirklich Beleidigungen, veröffentlichen persönlicher Daten oder sonstiger Schrott.
Also es gibt da keine, ich sehe da, ja aber auch da wieder ist sozusagen, da geht es wieder der Grundsatz, wenn etwas sozusagen nicht seine Unschuld beweisen kann, wird es erst mal gelöscht und sozusagen mit dieser Argumentation, da gibt es viele Beleidigungen, landen dann halt auch einfach viele Sachen.
Also vor allen Dingen ist das ja völlig unproblematisch, man kann das ja kategorisieren, weil die Löschungen sind ja alle begründet. Also wenn man sich die Löschbegründung anguckt, dann treten natürlich die Sachen Beleidigungen oder persönliche Daten auf, aber die in den Orkus zu schmeißen, ok, da hat niemand was dagegen, aber warum sind nicht die Sachen, die irgendwie wegen mangelnder Relevanz oder wegen Original Research gelöscht werden, warum sind die nicht öffentlich, dafür gibt es keinen guten Grund.
Ja, es ist einfach der Grund, dass Wikipedia nicht das Projekt ist, das das auf dem Schirm hat. Also Wikipedia wollte halt eine Enzyklopädie sein, keine Datenbank, keine Halde für Artikel, die halt eben offensichtlich unbedeutend sind und insofern muss da jemand anderes ein Projekt dafür starten. Und das hab ich ja gerade gesagt, also die Wikipedia ist eine Enzyklopädie.
Heute am letzten Mittwoch im Monat, wie immer das Chaos Radio zu Gast sind bei mir Frank Rieder. Frank Rieder von Chaos Computer Club. Ich bin Sago von Wikipedia Admin. Wir reden heute darüber, wie die Wikipedia funktioniert und die Frage, um die sich jetzt im Moment hanealaustriert ist sozusagen, da werden viele Sachen gelöscht und vielleicht will man die trotzdem sehen. Warum kann man die nicht angucken? Und Sago sagt, naja, dafür ist die Wikipedia eigentlich gar nicht da. Benny hat zu diesem Problem auch eine Frage oder eine Ansage. Hi Benny.
Es gab einen Anrufer, der hat vorgeschlagen, dass man doch einfach gucken könnte anhand der Zugriffszahlen auf verschiedene Artikel zu gucken, wie relevant die dort mit sind. Und da sehe ich eigentlich grundsätzlich das Problem, dass eigentlich erst mal alles an Wissen relevant ist und mal dann doch eigentlich eher in die andere Richtung filtern sollte, so wie es jetzt auch mehr oder weniger schon gemacht wird, zu gucken, was jetzt Beleidigungen oder irgendwie andere Sachen sind. Weil wenn jetzt immer nur rein nach der Zugriffszahlen oder der Wichtigkeit geht, dann tut man wissen, was eigentlich selten nachgefragt wird, nach einer gewissen Zeit irgendwo über den Jordan werfen. Und das geht der Welt dann insgesamt ja verloren. Nur weil es eben seltener irgendwo von Leuten beachtet wird.
Aber bist du in deiner Ansicht zu sagen, dass alles, was jemals drin stand, auch behalten werden sollte? Oder bist du dann auch für so Relevanzkriterien, also sagen nur Themen werden behalten, die bestimmte Kriterien erfüllen?
Ich bin erstmal grundsätzlich dafür, dass alles mitbehalten wird, weil mit den Relevanzkriterien und diesen 99 Prozent der Deutschen, die da uninteressant sind, da tut man eigentlich viel zu viel wissen, was die Menschheit mit hat. Dort erstmal von vornherein ausschließen.
Also die interessante Frage ist ja, wenn man sagt Popularität von Wissen, nehmen wir mal an, wir benutzen Popularität von Wissen als eine Messgröße, also als irgendein Wert für Relevanz. Nur mal ganz stumpf. Wir wissen alle, das würde dazu führen, dass der Britney Spears Artikel wahrscheinlich ungefähr 5 Megabyte groß ist. Aber wäre nicht zumindest Popularität eines Artikels, als Erschwerungsgrund für eine Löschung oder eine signifikante Kürzung des Artikels nicht eine sinnvolle Messgröße. Also man sagt, wenn ein Artikel zum Beispiel häufig verlinkt ist von außen, also das ist halt genau so ein Punkt, also der kommt auch immer wieder in Diskussionen, die wir so haben, ich schreibe einen Blog-Eintrag und ich referenziere auf die Wikipedia. Und dann ist plötzlich der Artikel halbes Jahr später weg, weil irgendwie er angeblich nicht mehr relevant ist. Was ja häufig auch passiert ist, dass Leute die Artikel nicht mögen, da passieren dann so Sachen, die kriegen sie im ersten Anlauf nicht so richtig weg, und dann werden die zu Tode gekürzt. Also dann wird immer eine Zeile nach der anderen abgebissen mit einer Bemerkung und am Ende wird der Artikel dann gelöscht wegen keiner Relevanz mehr. Das ist ja durchaus ein Vorgehen, was man durchaus beobachten kann.
Da gab es letztens auch mal ein Beispiel in der englischen Wikipedia, was da auch in dieser Diskussion rund um Moges und Fese aufgetaucht ist.
Und am Ende landen wir genau wieder da, dass dieser Anspruch, ein druckfähiges Lexikon zu machen, versus irgendwie ein Ding für die Netzwerke.
Ich muss sagen, das ist jetzt eine Position, mit der ich mich sehr schwer auseinandersetzen kann, ist zu sagen, wirklich 100 Prozent der Deutschen sind relevant. Weil ich viele Personen kenne, die mit Sicherheit nicht wollen, dass da die Wikipedia ein Personenverzeichnis wird, in dem wirklich alle Personen aufgeführt sind. Es hat auch ein bisschen was mit Daten zu tun oder so. Mit der Position kann ich mich eigentlich wenig auseinandersetzen.
Ich möchte kurz sagen, für alle Leute, die nicht wissen, warum jetzt gerade über alle Deutschen reden, es gab einen, also einen der Blockartikel, die dazu verlinkt und viel gelesen wurden, hieß, 99 Prozent aller Deutschen sind irrelevant. Ich glaube aber, dass man sagen kann, das ist natürlich eine provokante Bemerkung und niemand will wirklich, dass irgendwie alle Deutschen in der Wikipedia stehen. Was ich jetzt gerade spannend fand, war diese Löschgeschichte. Also irgendwie Leute kürzen Artikel, ist das sozusagen, also umsatzweise, dann wird irgendwann gelöscht, weil nicht einfach nicht genug drin steht. Ist das ein Vorgehen, was passiert?
Ja, das ist natürlich eine Ausnahme, aber klar passiert das. Also da habe ich auch schon mitbekommen. Muss man halt dagegen stehen und das dann eben wieder zurücksetzen und letztlich dann, wenn er wirklich keine Sachargumente hat. Also teilweise sind die Kürzungen auch Verbesserungen, weil vorher ist es halt ein Geschwurbeln, Geschwafeln, Ellenlanges, bla bla, mit Tausenden von irrelevanten Belegen. Und wenn da jemand das irgendwie kurz und knackig zusammenfasst, dann wirkt so ein Artikel fast schon bedeutender, als er vorher war. Weil ja, aber oft ist das auch bös gemeint. Das stimmt schon, das passiert schon. Einer ärgert sich über den anderen und macht in seinen Artikeln rum und versucht sie halt schlecht zu machen. Das gibt es, klar.
Benni, du meinst ja sozusagen, eigentlich sollte möglichst viel drinstehen und möglichst wenig löschen. Bist du denn selber in der Wikipedia aktiv?
Selber aktiv nicht, außer für ein Oben-Source-Projekt, was ich dort selber mit betreue und wo es in der Wikipedia eine Eintracht dazu gibt. Und das auch in der Wikipedia relativ stark benutzt wird sogar als Plug-in.
Okay, magst du noch kurz erzählen, was das ist?
Geysi, der Generic-Sündachs-Highlighter, also womit in den ganzen Programmierartikeln zum Beispiel die Sündachsvervorhebung für Beispielquelltexte gemacht wird.
Alles klar, dann sag ich auf jeden Fall mal vielen Dank für deine Arbeit. Denn es sind genau diese Leute, die es möglich machen, dass die Wikipedia in diesem großen Rahmen überhaupt funktioniert.
Ja, wollen wir mal Boris reinnehmen?
Wir wollen mal Boris reinnehmen. Tschüss Benni und hallo Boris.
Ja, hallo.
Ja, du wolltest was vorschlagen, glaube ich.
Ja, und zwar eher ein Vorschlag zu Güte. Und zwar gibt es ja schon seit längerem diese geprüften Artikel. Ihr hattet auch schon darüber geredet, dass die einmal kurz rangegesehen werden und ob dann nun was viel Veränderungen stattgefunden hat, ja oder nein. Wo ich auf jeden Fall zustimme, ist, dass Artikel gelöscht werden sollten, wo persönliche Daten veröffentlicht werden oder rein das Geschwimpfe ist. Aber ein Großvorschlag wäre doch tatsächlich, wenn man als Normalbürger auf die Wikipedia geht, kriegt man halt die normalen Artikel, aber wenn man sich angemeldet hat, kriegt man die ungeprüften Artikel und das kann ja auch wirklich die gesamte Bandbreite sein.
Dann hätten wir wieder ganz schön viel Kram.
Hättest du das für denkbar, sozusagen, es gibt so einen wissenschaftlichen Kern und eine...
Naja, das hätte den Vorteil, dass unheimlich viele Leute sich anmelden und vielleicht auch ein, zwei Sachen dazu beitragen, so Wikipedia, weil ohne Autoren schläft das ganze Ding ja ein.
Gibt es denn da so eine Diskussion innerhalb der Wikipedia, so was mal zu wagen?
Naja, ich meine, im Moment ist es ja so, es gibt über 300 Admins. Also ich kann nur sagen, bring dich ein, schreib gute Artikel. Dann wirst du Admin, dann kannst du alles sehen.
Nee, plus die Frage ist ja, ob so ein Vorgehen nicht sinnvoll wäre. Also dass man sagt, okay, es gibt Sachen, die sind halt gerade populär, die werden von den Leuten als momentan wichtig angesehen. Und da weiß man aber noch nicht, ob es langfristig bedeutet, zum Beispiel Piratenpartei. Der war 2006, war das ein Dush-Kandidat. Mit der Bemerkung wird eh nix. Also das war halt so im Wesentlichen das Fazit der Löschdiskussion. Und wie wir gerade sehen, hat die Piratenpartei mittlerweile eine Relevanz erreicht, so selbst nach allen Wikipedia-Kriterien. So und die interessante Frage wäre jetzt, ob man nicht sagen könnte, okay, wir gehen halt hin und sagen, wir bauen einen Gütesiegel, also sozusagen einen Kern der Wikipedia, der halt irgendwie den Brockhausansprüchen genügt und haben ansonsten aber noch einen Wikipedia-Light, wo halt einfach die Relevanzkriterien nicht ganz so hoch gehängt werden und von mir aus auch die Freiläge Feuerwehr hinter Butzendorf drauf ist. Wenn die Leute sich halt drum kümmern und die Artikel, sagen wir mal, wesentlich formal korrekt sind.
Formal korrekt, sondern halt viel kümmern. Wir sind im Moment, ich weiß nicht, ein paar tausend Leute nur, die sich um die ganzen Sachen kümmern. Und die Pflege ist halt das hauptsächliche Problem. Das heißt, wenn wir jetzt zehnmal so viele Leute wären, dann könnten wir vielleicht auch die...
Aber da beißt sich doch die KZNR 20. Wir haben doch gerade gehört, dass die Leute frustriert sind und aufgeben, weil sie keine Möglichkeit haben, sich einzubringen, sondern erst mal extrem hohe Hürden haben.
Ja, aber es gibt auch zum Beispiel Leute, denen es völlig egal ist und die sich selbst eine Meinung bilden möchten. Und wenn die die Möglichkeit haben, alle Artikel zu sehen, nun ausgenommen von den wirklichen Beschmutzungen, dann möchte ich das auch wirklich sehen. Egal, ob das nun jetzt eine tolle Enzyklopädie ist oder nicht. Ich möchte zumindest die Möglichkeit haben, die Artikel zu sehen. Und das muss ja auch nicht sofort auf der Startseite da sein.
Na ja, also wie gesagt, das für mich wäre halt so eine Klassifizierung zu sagen, okay, der Artikel entspricht jetzt nicht den Relevanzkriterien, aber ansonsten ist er nicht beleidigend, aber es ist halt irgendwie keine persönlichen Daten drin, ist halt nicht enzyklopädisch relevant, aber zumindest ist er lustig.
Ja, es schafft halt eben zusätzliche... Also ich sehe das immer aus dem Admin-Auge. Das heißt, ich müsste jetzt nicht nur entscheiden, bleibt der Artikel, wird der Artikel gelöscht. Arbeite ich den Artikel in einen anderen Übersichtsartikel ein, diese Möglichkeit besteht ja auch immer, sondern verschiebe ich den jetzt auch noch in diesen anderen Namensraum, in denen nur bestimmte Benutzer Zugriff haben. Das heißt, ich habe dann irgendwie wieder eine neue Bürokratie und wieder neue Richtlinien, an die ich mich halten muss.
Genau, genau, das Gegenteil wäre der Fall, wenn man sagt, Artikel, die ihr halt nicht in zu... Naja, ich meine, versucht nochmal gerade aus dem...
Ich schreibe jetzt einen Artikel über dein Hemd, stell den dann da ein und dann bleibt der da. Wem soll das denn nutzen? Das ist doch kein Wissen.
Hey, ich meine, du weißt nicht so über mein Hemd, aber vielleicht habe ich hier gerade genau das T-Shirt hinter aller Hafenwurfe.
Das detailliert ja auch keinen, den Artikel. Und deswegen guckt auch keiner rein. Also, wen stört es? Das ist doch wirklich... Platzverbrauch kann es echt nicht sein.
Naja, das ist so ein bisschen so... Da beißt sich halt die Katze in den Schwanz. Ihr sagt ja, Wikipedia hat zu wenig Leute. Das ist ja auch immer das Argument dafür, wieso der Wissensraum begrenzt sein soll. Also de facto, wenn man jetzt das Argument mal schön zuspitzt, sagt man, sagt ihr, wir haben nur so viele Lämmer, oder Lämmerter, wie wir maintainen können. Also wie wir tatsächlich irgendwie gewartet bekommen. Und wenn man aber sagt, wir senken jetzt mal zumindest für einen Teil des Namensraums einfach die Kriterien, dann entsteht da plötzlich eine ganz neue Gruppe von Autoren, die in der Lage ist, halt einfach Sachen zu schreiben. Und da kann man immer noch gucken, wer was taugt und wer Schrott schreibt.
Ja, es werden halt viele, viele Wikipedianer abhauen. Die werden dann wirklich zu Neul gehen oder die werden doch noch bei Wikivise einziehen oder so. Wir haben ja ungefähr das Mantra, dass man nichts aus der englischsprachigen Wikipedia übersetzen kann, weil die Artikel halt unseren qualitativen Ansprüchen nicht genügen. Und die Qualitätsautoren wollen wir natürlich auch unbedingt behalten. Wir wollen vor allen Dingen neue Qualitätsautoren auch gewinnen. Also Leute aus der Wissenschaft, die irgendwie an der Uni sind. Das können von mir aus auch Erstsemester sein, wenn die wissen, wie man in der Bibliothek recherchiert. Und die Leute wollen wir natürlich auch nicht verlieren. Und die werden gehen. Also den Prozess gab es ja schon. Es gab ja schon mal eine Fawke von Leuten, die gesagt haben, die Qualität in der Wikipedia reicht denen einfach nicht. Die wollen jetzt wirklich nur Zitierfähiges veröffentlichen.
Ja, bloß genau da sind wir mit einem zweiten Kernproblem. Also wenn ich jetzt eine Studienarbeit in der Uni entreiche oder eine Magisterarbeit und habe da Wikipedia-Verweise drin, dann kriegt die um die Ohren gehauen und zwar zu Recht. Das heißt, das Ziel der Zitierfähigkeit ist ohnehin nicht erlangenbar?
Nein, das ist nicht gewünscht.
Nein, das ist de facto nicht erlangenbar.
Wir wollen das auch gar nicht, weil wir wollen ja weiter, dass jeder sein Wissen einbringen kann.
Aber de facto, also ich meine, bloß da passt es ja gerade nicht.
Genau, wir bewegen uns ja so Wattebausch-mäßig halt in verschiedene Zwiebeln, in verschiedene Interessen. Also wir wollen nicht zitierbar werden. Das heißt, wir wollen nicht, dass gar keiner mehr mitschreiben kann, aber wir wollen, dass jeder, der ein bisschen was an Material zusammentragen kann, das halt auch in die Wikipedia packen kann und damit allen zugänglich machen. Darum geht es ja.
Na, aber das scheint ja mittlerweile nicht mehr der Kern des Ganzen zu sein. Also wenn ich jetzt an diesen Artikel im Wikipedia-Kurier z.B. denke, der ist leider jetzt schon gelöscht, aber...
Der ist nicht gelöscht, der ist in der Visionsgeschichte immer jederzeit abrufbar.
Na gut, also jedenfalls ist er jetzt nicht mehr vor, auf der Frontpage zu sehen, der da sagte, Blogs werden im Wesentlichen von Prekariat und zweitklassigen Wissenschaftlern betrieben.
Genau, ich hab Prekariat verlinkt übrigens in dem Artikel.
Aber dann sagt man halt, ok, eigentlich wollen wir den Pöbel da draußen ja nicht. Also wir wollen auch das Wissen des Pöbels nicht und wir wollen auch nicht die Arbeitskraft und die Artikel, die wir schreiben könnten, sondern wir wollen halt nur Leute mindestens mit einem akademischen Abschluss. Aber offensichtlich gibt es ja einen großen Bedarf danach zu sagen, ok, da wir die Wikipedia ohnehin nicht zitieren können und sie nicht den wissenschaftlichen Ansprüchen genügt zitierfähig zu sein, ist das dann nicht eine Illusion, die da betrieben wird? Also zu sagen, wir versuchen jetzt hier einen Zitierfegen?
Das ist jedenfalls nicht greifbar.
Es scheint mir so, dass die Diskussion dahin geht, wie viel nehmen wir jetzt rein eigentlich? Du sagst, Sargo, der Wikipedia-Admin sagt, wir nehmen halt nur das rein, was wissenschaftlich belegbar ist, auf Papier gedruckt und mit Quellen. Und viele Leute draußen sagen, das muss eigentlich schon viel mehr sein. Es ist jetzt auch gerade der Unterschied gefallen zwischen, du hast gerade erzählt, Sargo, die englische Wikipedia, da darf man keine Artikel übersetzen, weil die den Qualitätskriterien nicht genügt sind.
Nein, das ist so ein Bormor im Ende-Deutschsprachigen Wikipedia.
Aber genau um diesen Unterschied geht es auch Streethoff. Hallo, guten Tag.
Ja, hi.
Du willst etwas zum Unterricht zwischen Englischer und deutscher Wikipedia sagen?
Auf jeden Fall. Also erstmal schönen Gruß an den Blaine. Den hab ich schon echt lang nicht mehr gehört. Ist auch ein alter Hanoveran aus der Leitstelle 511 bei uns.
Okay, so viel zu den Details, jetzt zur Wikipedia.
Jetzt zur Wikipedia. Ja, also ich guck zumindest erstmal in die englische Wikipedia, weil ich da viel, viel mehr finde, was mich interessiert. Problem an der deutschen Wikipedia finde ich echt diese Relevanzdiskussion. Das finde ich recht grenzwertig. Das ist eine offene Wissensdatenbank im Prinzip. Artikel löscht wegen einer Relevanz. Gegen einen Kumpel von mir aus Augsburg, ein Wikipedia-User, DK64, hat eingestellt letztes Jahr ein tolles Modul, was es für den Commodore 64 als neue Hardware gibt. Das nennt sich 1541Ultimate. Das ist eine Floppy-Emulation, die eine echte 1541 Floppy für den Commodore 64 emuliert. War damals dann halt so, hat einen super Artikel geschrieben, eingestellt, gelöscht von einem Atari-User, wieder eingestellt, wieder gelöscht.
Wir reden jetzt einmal noch von der deutschen Wikipedia.
Wieder eingestellt, natürlich in der deutschen Wikipedia. In der englischen, also er hat es dann später in einem reinen Commodore 64-Wiki eingestellt. Mittlerweile gibt es einen Artikel in der deutschen Wikipedia zu dem Modul, weil es anscheinend relevant genug ist mittlerweile. Die 1541 Ultimate halt.
Okay, wäre deine Forschung jetzt die deutschen, sollen so werden wie die englischen?
Also ich fand das halt damals traurig, weil der Artikel war gut. Guckt man sich an, 1541 Ultimate in der Wikipedia ist im Prinzip so ein Artikel.
Wir wissen jetzt, dass du den Floppy-Controller total toll findest, aber wie sollte sich die deutsche Wikipedia in Zukunft verhalten, so wie die englische oder eigenen Stil entwickeln?
Ja gut, also ich fand das halt damals schade, dass aufgrund von Relevanz, derjenige hat die Hardware halt als Hobbyprojekt gebaut irgendwie.
Ich fürchte, wir kommen hier nicht mehr zum Punkt, sondern wir bleiben hängen bei einem 1441 Controller, was echt ein Controller für einen tollen Computer war. Aber genau, gut. Wir wollen jetzt aber herausfinden, was ist mit der Wikipedia, mit der deutschen Wikipedia? Wie stellt ihr euch vor, wie das sein könnte in Zukunft? Jens hat dazu auch was zu sagen. Tag Jens. Wie sieht deine Wikipedia aus? Wie hältst du sie gerne?
Also ich hab zwei Vorschläge zu machen. Zum einen wäre es vielleicht gut, von dem Blick auf eine Enzyklopädie jetzt mal zu abstrahieren. Also es wird immer gesagt, Wissensdatenbank, ja okay, aber da bietet das Internet doch mehr heutzutage. Also ich kann Wissen erfassen, ich kann Wissen vernetzen und ich kann Texts vergeben und so weiter. Und da könnte die Enzyklopädie doch einfach eine Untermenge der Wissensdatenbank sein. Und da müsste ich dann nicht so schnell zum Löschding greifen.
Das hört jetzt ein bisschen verschwobelt an.
Wikipedia zum Beispiel jeden Artikel erst mal behalten und nur löschen, wenn es absolut notwendig wäre. Und dann könnte man bestimmte Prädikate vergeben für Artikel, die sozusagen für eine Enzyklopädie-Version geeignet werden. Und dann könnte ich zum Beispiel anschalten, ich will suchen nach allen Artikeln oder ich will suchen nur nach Enzyklopädie-tauglichen Artikeln. So ähnlich wie vielleicht so ein Qualitätsmerkmal wie die gesichtete Version, sag ich mal.
Okay, Jens sagt also, in Wikipedia soll irgendwie alles rein und die Qualitätsunterschiede machen wir dann einfach durch Label durch, die da vergeben werden. Da ist Merlin nicht ganz der Ansicht. Hi Merlin.
Hallo.
Wie willst du die Wikipedia haben?
Ja, also ich bin im Grunde der Meinung, dass die Schnittmenge größer sein sollte. Also dass ja in der Tat mehr behalten werden sollte, wenn Artikel gut sind. Aber ich glaube trotzdem, dass beispielsweise Spezial-Wikis auf jeden Fall eine Daseinsberechtigung haben. Und man sollte Wikipedia nicht damit verwechseln, quasi als alles, als Google oder was auch immer. Google wird ja nicht umsonst allwissende Müllhalle genannt.
Das ist der Schwitzname, den ich für Wikipedia kenne.
Nee, das ist der für Google bei uns.
Manche sagen so, manche sagen so, du willst aber nicht alles in der Wikipedia haben, wo würdest du die Grenze ziehen?
Die Grenze ist natürlich immer eine schwierige Sache. Aktuell merkt man es ja, dass Fefe genau an der Grenze liegen, finde ich. Beziehungsweise darüber, aber spielt jetzt ja keine Rolle. Ich glaube eher, dass das eine Lösung des Konflikts wäre, das eben so ein bisschen ins Bewusstsein zu ziehen und eine bessere Vernetzung zwischen Wikis zu kriegen. Dass ich beispielsweise Star Wars Wikis oder South Park Wikis in irgendeiner Form gut verknüpft hab, damit ich einerseits in der Wikipedia, die so einen allgemeinen Bereich, wie man das jetzt genau auch immer definiert, einen allgemeinen Bereich abdeckt und die Spezial-Wikis dann eben den Rest machen. Beziehungsweise nicht den Rest, aber eben wesentlich spezielle Ideen.
Konkret der Fall, es ging hier um diesen Verein MOGIS, der wurde gelöscht und du sagst, wenn jetzt für die Löschung gesprochen wird, heißt das dann, es existiert in der Wikipedia dann ein Link auf das Spezial-Wiki, wo es einen Artikel dazu gibt oder wie soll das sein?
Die genaue Umsetzung, da weiß ich das, um alt zu sein, nicht. Ich wüsste nicht, wie man das realisieren kann. Ich bin da in der Form kein Techniker.
Aber das ist deine Vorstellung sozusagen?
Ja, ich stell mir das in der Form eher wie so ein Such-Interface vor, wie man das zum Beispiel auf wikipedia.de im Endeffekt hat, dass dann eben mehrere Wikis, viel mehr Wikis umfasst.
Wer soll dann deiner Meinung nach entscheiden, ob der Artikel in der normalen Wikipedia am Start ist oder in so einem Spezial-Wiki?
Mir geht es jetzt ganz konkret noch gar nicht um die Entscheidung, sondern eher um das Gesamt, also insgesamt um das Bewusstsein, dass eben Wikipedia nicht für alles ist, sondern so eine Gesamtmenge abgrenzt. Und die genauen Grenzen kann man eben nicht ziehen. Ich würde zum Beispiel sagen, ein guter Artikel über ein Thema, was vielleicht nicht ganz so relevant ist, auf jeden Fall behalten.
Also auf jeden Fall diese Entscheidung treffen und sagen, im Zweifelsfall...
Genau, ich brauche jetzt ja nicht von Wireshark oder so über irgendwelche Funktionen. Dann Artikel, der wäre ja in der Wikipedia völlig unsinnig und fehler am Platz. Der gehört dann eben ins Wireshark-Wiki.
Also Merlin sagt, Artikel trennen. Es gibt die ganz relevanten, die sollen bei der Wikipedia stehen bleiben. Und es gibt dann die, die so ein bisschen weniger relevant sind. Und die kommen dann in Spezial-Wikis.
Ich habe eine kleine Geschichte. Und zwar habe ich vor ungefähr drei Jahren, wollte ich bei uns auf der Arbeit auch so eine Wissensdatenbank einführen und habe meinem Chef davon erzählt. Und der war dann auch so, ja, das nutzt doch keiner. Und das sind irgendwie verwaiste Wissensleichen. Und er möchte so ähnlich wie die Wikipedia haben, dass quasi nur wichtige Sachen drin sind. Und das dann quasi damit abgetan. Und mein Argument dafür, was er dann auch akzeptiert hat, war, wenn es bei uns auf der Arbeit nur fünf Leute betrifft, die es interessant finden, dann hat es doch schon eine Relevanz. Oder dann ist es doch schon wertig. Und das hat er dann akzeptiert mit dem Argument, dass es, wenn es doch bloß eine Handvoll Leute interessiert, dann hat es doch einen Sinn.
Okay, aber wie viel wäre ein, also für die Wikipedia braucht man da irgendwie so ein Kriterium. Was würdest du sagen, wie viel muss eine Handvoll sein? Also reichen da wirklich so, wenn fünf Leute sich mal sagen, hier so, ich finde den Artikel interessant, dann ist gut?
Ja, wo du jetzt auf der Firma bleibst mit fünf Leuten bei 200 ist natürlich nicht so viel im Vergleich zum Internet. Aber im Prinzip ist es doch dann fast so gut wie alles. Abgesehen ist natürlich von Vandalismus und irgendwie Fäkalsprachbeschreibungen und sowas. Ist doch dann eigentlich alles wichtig, weil denen es interessiert, oder die Handvoll, die sind tatsächlich interessiert. Und wenn es nur 50 Leute sind, die sich für den Kleintierzüchterverein in Oberammergau interessieren, dann sind es eben nur die 50 und alle anderen stören sich im Prinzip nicht an diesem Artikel.
Okay, Mark sagt also auch, es soll in der Wikipedia all das reingenommen werden, was irgendjemand interessiert, solange es so eine Handvoll Leute ist, weil es stört ja keinen, wenn da mehr drin steht, was man irgendwie nicht genau lesen will. So, wenn ihr mal sehen wollt, wie ein Chat feiert, dann empfehle ich euch jetzt auf Chaosradio.de zu gehen, dort den Link zum Chat rauszusuchen oder ihr geht einfach direkt zu Freenode in den Raum Chaosradio, denn ich werde jetzt ankündigen, was nach den Nachrichten passiert. Was nach den Nachrichten passiert, ist, dass wir mit Fefe sprechen werden, auch vom Chaos Computer Club. Der hat ganz viel darüber geblockt mit dem Wikipedia-Problem. Vorher aber, wie gesagt, machen wir Nachrichten weiter... Oh Gott, es wird wirklich Zeit, dass die Nachrichten mit Weiter- und Verkehr kommen. Außerdem spielen wir noch einen Song vorher, der sich von Frank Rieger, der heute hier zu Gast ist, gewünscht wurde, wo ich mich ja gefragt habe, wenn man die Chaos Leute fragt, was soll man machen, hauptsache elektronisch, das Rest ist eigentlich Latte, aber immer wenn die so einen speziellen Wunsch anbringen, dann hört sich das überhaupt gar nicht elektronisch an. Magst du kurz sagen, was wir gleich hören?
Genau, wir hören gerade gleich die norwegische Band Katzenjammer, die neulich durchs Netz geistert war. Wir haben es ja manchmal hier mit schönen jungen Frauen, mit großen Bessen und die fallen auch in diese Region.
Das ist Katzenjammermusik, die noch nicht zu Ende ist anscheinend.
Ich glaube, wir können es abblenden.
Aber andererseits, diese schöne Musik, die hört im Chaos-Radio, wo wir gleich mit Fefe darüber reden werden, was ihnen in Wikipedia so stört. Vorher gibt es aber wie bereits angekündigt und wortgewaltig versprochen Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr.
So klang das Ende ihres exklusiven Fritz-Radio-Konzerts im September. Aber zum Glück liegt ja in jedem Ende ein neuer Anfang.
Fritz präsentiert die Editors.
Samstag, 21.
November. Editors, live in der Berliner Koloniale.
Karten gibt's überall, wo's Karten gibt.
Zum Beispiel auch auf Hipstik.
Editors, live in Berlin und präsentiert von Fritz.
Und das hört man um kurz nach halb 12. Nachrichten mit Kaietan Dürlich.
Die neue Bundesregierung hat ihre Arbeit aufgenommen. Kanzlerin Merkel und die 15 Ressortchefs von Union und FDP legten ihren Amtseid ab. Bundespräsident Köhler hatte den Ministern die Ernennungsurkunden überreicht. Bundeskanzlerin Merkel wurde am Vormittag vom Bundestag für eine zweite Amtszeit gewählt. Am Abend traf sie im Rahmen ihrer ersten Auslandsreise nach der Bundestagswahl in Paris an. In Brandenburg haben sich SPD und Linke auf die Verteilung der Ministerposten verständigt. Die SPD bekommt fünf Ministerien, die Linke übernimmt als neuer Koalitionspartner vier Ministerposten. Der bisherige Finanzminister Speer von der SPD wechselt in das Innenressort. Neue Wissenschaftsministerin wird seine Parteigenossin Münch. Bildungsminister Ruprecht behält sein Amt. Die Linke übernimmt unter anderem die Ministerien für Wirtschaft und für Umwelt. Während des Besuchs von US-Ausministerin Clinton ist Pakistan vom schwersten Terroranschlag seit zwei Jahren erschüttert worden. Unbekannte zündeten eine Autobombe in Peshawar, die mindestens 90 Menschen tötete. 200 weitere wurden verletzt, als der Sprengsatz in einem belebten Geschäftsviertel detonierte. Clinton verurteilte die Tat als feige. Die Pakistanische Armee führt zurzeit eine Offensive gegen die Taliban durch. Die Weltgesundheitsorganisation will 200 Millionen Dosen des Impfstoffs gegen die Schweinegrippe an Entwicklungsländer verteilen. Das kündigte WHO-Generaldirektorin Chan zum Abschluss eines viertägigen Besuchs in Kuba an. Im November könne mit der Verteilung bereits begonnen werden, hieß es, nach Angaben der WHO sind bisher weltweit etwa 5000 Menschen an der Krankheit gestorben. Zum Fußball Bayern München hat das Viertelfinale im DFB-Pokal erreicht. Der deutsche Rekordmeister gewann beim Eintracht Frankfurt mit 4 zu 0. Ebenfalls weiter sind Schalke 04 und Werder Bremen. Die Bremer besiegten Kaiserslautern mit 3 zu 0. Schalke kam ebenfalls zu einem 3 zu 0 Erfolg bei 1860 München. In einer weiteren Achtelfinalpartie bezwang Hoffenheim den Zweitligisten Koblenz mit 4 zu 0. Heute Nacht, da ist es wieder ziemlich bewölkt draußen. Es kann immer wieder regnen und die Temperaturen fallen heute Nacht bis auf 6 Grad ab. Hier sind die aktuellen Werte in Cottbus und Angermünde. Da sind es aktuell 8 Grad. Trotz dem Frankfurt Neuropin Wittenberge immer noch 9 und in Berlin Werte zwischen 9 und 10 Grad. Morgen wird es dann in der ersten Tageshefte ziemlich bewölkt sein. Später lockert es langsam ein bisschen auf. Und es wird morgen wieder ein bisschen kühler werden in Berlin und Brandenburg. Und das mit Höchstwerten von gerade mal 11 Grad. Bitte Vorsicht, alle die noch auf der Stadt Autobahn unterwegs sind, auf der A111 Stadt Einwerth zwischen dem Weidmanns-Osterdamm, Hermsdorfer-Damm und der Holzhoser Straße, da ist gesperrt, da wird geballt, äh gebaut, nicht geballt, gebaut. Und außerdem auch Richtung Süden auf der Stadt Autobahn zwischen dem Weidmanns-Osterdamm und dem Festplatz, da ist voll gesperrt. Da ist eine Umleitung ausgeschüllert. Und alle, die noch mit der Berliner U-Bahn unterwegs sind, die sollten auch passen, wenn sie mit der U1 fahren zwischen Gleisdreck und Wittenbergsplatz. Da fahren nämlich keine Züge. Am besten da an die Linie U2 ausweichen. Außerdem ist der Bahnhof Kurfürstenstraße gesperrt, geschlossen, nicht gesperrt, man kommt aber auch durcheinander. Und bei der U8 wird ab 10 Uhr zwischen Kottbursator und der Heinrich-Heine-Straße gependelt. Und das mit Bussen.
Können wir das einfach in Zukunft so machen, wenn die Verkehrsmeldungen leer sind? Wenn es mehr als zwei Seiten sind, sagst du einfach zu Hause bleiben?
Die waren doch fünf Seiten. Ne, zwei Seiten. Ich bin auch durch.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 100 3, 2, dann Fritz im Cottbus.
Mit Markus Richter, das bin ich, der Moderator des Chaos Radio. Blue Moon natürlich zu Gast, jemand vom Chaos Computer Club, das ist Frank Rieder. Und dann noch jemand, wo im Chat gerade gesagt wurde, wer ist denn der arme Exkludist, auf dem gerade rumgehackt wird?
Exklusionist.
Eine weitere Frage. Möchtest du erklären, was mit diesem Wort gemeint ist?
Das ist eine kleine Spiegelfechterei. Der erste Eintrag bei den Relevanzkriterien, der sagt eben Exklusion, Inklusion, was sollen wir reinnehmen, was sollen wir rausmachen, Exklusion, Ausschluss. Ich bin ganz sicher kein Exklusionist und kein Inklusionist, sondern versuche halt einfach nur festzustellen, ob irgendwas eine gewisse Bedeutung hat. Und das möchte ich dann auch gerne behalten und ausgebaut sehen.
Also Exklusionisten sind Leute, die sagen, eigentlich muss alles raus, was nicht knallhart irgendwie total geil ist.
Oder super geschrieben.
Oder super geschrieben und inklusive Nerven, da hab ich auch schon, egal. Andere Diskussionen, jetzt gibt es auch noch die Inklusionisten, die sagen, eigentlich muss alles rein, was irgendjemand irgendwann mal irgendwie interessiert hat. Und das sind die beiden Leute, die sich in der Wikipedia streiten, denn das ist das Thema, was wir heute noch, naja, 24 Minuten knapp besprechen. Die Frage, was muss denn alles in die Wikipedia und was soll draußen bleiben? Und wir haben jetzt am Telefon einen, der, ich will nicht sagen Verursacher, aber sozusagen jemand, der die Diskussion vorangetrieben hat, könnte man sagen. Hi, Fefe. Guten Abend.
Also erst mal muss ich euch von einem Linguistik-Professor mitteilen, dass es Excludist heißt und nicht Exclusionist.
Ja, das außen vielleicht in der Wikipedia heißt es Exclusionist. Ja, beides hab ich, also beides hat kaum, kaum, kaum Ergebnisse, wenn du das suchst. Weder bei Google Scholar noch irgendwie Google Books. Also es sind beides Begriffe aus dem Luftlernraum.
Das können wir ja mal in allerlöscht Diskussion ausreinbartieren. Also, ja, was ich eigentlich sagen wollte ist, dieses Relevanzgetägen, da gibt es eigentlich ein ganz anschauliches Gegenargument gegen. Und zwar hat Google und eigentlich alle großen Suchmaschinen und Metasuchmaschinen inzwischen das so, dass wenn man nach irgendeinem Wort sucht und es gibt einen Wikipedia-Eintrag, dann ist der ganz oben. Ja, und das ist eine Sache, das ist eigentlich eine Multimillionenindustrie, das Webseitenkontext kriegen und wenn man sich überlegt, dass es so weit ist, dass Wikipedia einfach immer ganz oben ist, dann muss man auch die Relevanz andersrum sehen. Das ist nämlich nicht die Sache, die Wikipedia für relevant hält, sondern die Sache, die in Wikipedia gesucht werden von den Leuten. Und das sind dann einfach die Sachen, die in Google gesucht werden natürlich. Weil einfach mehr Leute bei Google irgendwas fragen als Wikipedia. Und wenn Wikipedia einen Alltag hat, ist der ganz oben. Das heißt, dieses Selbstverständnis, was Wikipedia da hat, kommt meines Erachtens daher, dass Google nur linked, wenn Google weiß, was Wikipedia was hat. Ihr seht einfach gar nicht, wie viele Leute Sachen suchen, die ihr nicht habt. Und daher diese Überlegung, dass man einfach Sachen, die man selbst nicht für relevant hält, nicht in die Wikipedia macht, die ist aber nicht zielführend an der Stelle. Denn ihr macht das ja nicht für euch, sondern ihr macht das für eure Zielgruppe. Und eure Zielgruppe sind durch diese Regelung alle Leute, die Suchmaschinen benutzen. Und das müsst ihr euch vor Augen halten, wenn ihr da rumiditiert in der Wikipedia. Deswegen hab ich neulich geblockt, dass ich finde, Relevanz sollte anders definiert werden. Nämlich, dass man sagt, wenn das, was im Artikel steht, mit dem Thema nichts zu tun hat, also wenn da irgendwie Blabla steht, oder irgendwie Frau Schmidt ist doof, und die Schüler vandalisiert hat, keine Frage, das kommt raus. Aber ansonsten, wenn das mit der Überschrift was zu tun hat, sollte man das als Relevant ansehen und den drin lassen. Ich bin der Meinung, als ich mein, ich werd häufig von Wikipedia-Dotten angesprochen in letzter Zeit. Ja, ich weiß auch nicht. Und eine der häufigen Sachen, die da kommt, ist eben, ja, aber es gibt doch diese Relevanzkriterien, die stehen in der Wikipedia drin. Und das stimmt auch, die kann jeder mal googeln, Wikipedia Relevanzkriterien ist der erste. Und das ist eine L-Lange-Liste. Also bei mir stoß da zum Beispiel, was war das Beispiel, was ich hatte, ich glaube Sinsa oder so was, Weinhersteller, es gibt für jeden Kack, gibt es da irgendwie einen Unterabschnitt. Und das sind ja keine ehrenlosen Gesetze, die von Gott gegeben, auf dem Mount Sinai, den Menschen auf Steintafeln gegeben wurden, sondern das haben auch irgendwelche Leute irgendwann definiert. Und so muss man das sehen.
Lass mich mal kurz zusammenfassen. Also im Prinzip hast du zwei Ansprüche an die Wikipedia, wie die Artikel sozusagen aufnehmen sollen. Wenn Leute das wissen wollen, und zwar absehbar aus irgendwelchen Google- oder Suchmaschinesuche, dann soll es dazu auch einen Artikel geben. Und wenn der Artikel sozusagen so geschrieben ist, dass er tatsächlich was aussagt und mit dem Wort zu tun hat, worüber der Artikel benannt ist, dann soll das drin bleiben.
Genau, also ich gebe mal ein Beispiel. Wenn ich jetzt hier rumlaufe und ich siehe die Frauenkirche, okay, das ist halt ein bekanntes Merkmal, das gibt es in Wikipedia. Und jetzt gehe ich irgendwie drei Häuser weiter. Ich bin dann in Dresden dran. Und da steht die Gemäldegalerie. Und gut, das steht jetzt vielleicht auch noch drin. Da habe ich nicht geguckt. Aber ich würde sagen, da findet sich irgendein Haus, wo irgendein Schild vorsteht. Und ich möchte jetzt wissen, was ist das für ein Haus? Und da würde mir schon völlig reichen, wenn da drin steht, das ist ein Haus aus dem Barock gebaut von dem und dem dann und dann. Das würde mir völlig reichen. Also ich erwarte gar nicht, dass da von enzyklopedischer Länge irgendwie die Details drinstehen, wie viele Treppen es da gibt und so. Das beziehe mich da alles nicht. Aber einfach schon so zwei, drei Grunddinger, die drinstehen, würden mir schon völlig reichen. Ich meine, die Frage ist, ich kann auch immer noch weggehen. Wenn ich hingehe zu Wikipedia, ich finde diesen Artikel und da steht nichts drin, was mir geholfen hat, dann gehe ich weg, da ist doch kein Schaden entstanden.
Aber würdest du dann auch sozusagen Relevanzkriterien anwenden, im Sinne von, auch dein Beispielhaus war jetzt aus dem Barock und wurde von jemand gebaut, das einen Namen an vielleicht schon mal gehört hatte, oder darf man dann wirklich zu jedem Haus einen Artikel schreiben?
Naja, das Problem ist, dass es da namensfreie mit Kollisionen gibt. Also zum Beispiel ganz normale Menschen Namen. Da gibt es halt, weiß nicht, wie viele Heiko Schmidt es in Deutschland gibt, weiß ich jetzt nicht. Also da muss man irgendwo eine Linie ziehen, das sehe ich schon auch so.
Okay, wer soll entscheiden?
Na das muss man eben in Ruhe ausdiskutieren. Ich will das auch nicht entscheiden. Aber ich sage, wenn es irgendwas gibt, wo ich was zu google und da gibt es keinen Artikel, dann wäre ein Artikel ein beliebiger Artikel mehr wert als diesen nicht existierenden Artikel. Und ich finde, in dem Moment, wo ein Mehrwert denkbar ist durch einen Artikel in der Wikipedia, sollte man den auch nicht löschen, wenn es ihn gibt. Selbst wenn er grocken Scheiße und voller Rechtsschreibfehler ist.
Na gut, das brachte ich glaube ich noch mal ein weiteres Thema zu diskutieren, ob man das dann wirklich behalten wollen würde. Aber auf jeden Fall mehr Artikel und zwar immer dann, wenn sich jemand interessiert. Die Frage, die ich mir jetzt gerade stelle, ist so, also tendenziell, gefühlt würde ich sagen, ja, ja, aber wer soll das alles machen?
Das Problem ist ja, dass die Leute im Moment schon versuchen, sowas zu machen. Also dieser Commodore-Mensch war ein gutes Beispiel. Das ist ein absolutes Randgruppen-Ding. Da werden vielleicht 100 Leute im Jahr, wenn es hoch kommt, draufklicken. Aber für die ist das ein Mehrwert. Und deswegen finde ich, wenn...
Ich habe heute mehr Hitz bei meinen Artikeln.
Das ist ja genau der Punkt, den ich versucht habe vorhin zu machen, dass wenn man mehr Leute zulässt mitzumachen, dann löst sich genau dieses Problem auch.
Das irritieren wir im Moment nicht. Also ich will jetzt hier nicht meine Mail vorlesen, aber ich kriege im Moment echt viele Mails von Leuten, die mir also alle als Grundthener schreiben, ja, ich habe ja auch mal bei der Wikipedia mitgearbeitet, aber habe vor einigen Jahren aufgehört, weil mir diese barbaren Diskussionen mit den Lösch-Adminen zu blöde waren. Und ich meine, ich will es jetzt hier nicht irgendwie, das ist sicher nicht der einzige Mensch, der Standdienste gibt, aber da sind also signifikante Anzahl von Leute, meldet mir das gerade. Und das kann man nicht einfach irgendwie beiseite legen und sich dann auf der anderen Seite wundern, dass die Anzahl der Leute, die mitarbeiten wollen, abnimmt. Ja, also das hat Frank schon sehr richtig gesagt, das beißt sich selber in den Schwanz. Und wenn wir jetzt sagen, wir wollen, dass mehr Leute mithelfen, dann müssen wir eben auch die Schranke dafür senken, dass mehr Leute mitarbeiten wollen. Und das Erste, was man tun kann, ist, wenn man öffentlich kommuniziert. Ja, wir sehen, dass es hier ein Problem gibt mit der Intervanz und dass Artikel gelöscht werden, in die andere Leute, die ihr Herzensblut investiert haben. Und natürlich gibt es da immer Probleme, wenn irgendjemand einen Marketinger hochlegt oder so. Das bestreitet sich ja gar nicht, das kann man alles ausdiskutieren. Aber so, wie es im Moment ist, dass jemand sich da einen Tag Zeit nimmt, um einen schönen Artikel zu, was weiß ich, von mir aus sogar ein Produkt, ein Computerspiel, irgendwas, was wahrscheinlich überhaupt nicht relevant ist. Ein Computerspiel von jemandem, zum Beispiel eines von Hardrock-Klienten. Also bei mir ist es durchaus so, dass ich bei der englischen Wikipedia mir irgendwelche Computerspielartikel durchlese. Und die haben in der Encyclopädie nichts verloren. Aber das ist ein echter Mehrwert für mich. Weil da steht dann drin, der Publisher, so und so, das ist dann und dann erschienen. Die Ratings waren so und so, mit Link auf Metacritic oder was weiß ich. Das ist ein echter Mehrwert. Und das finde ich gut, dass die englische Wikipedia das hat. Und wenn wir Deutschen da nicht so deutsch wären, an der Stelle, sondern einfach mal so ein bisschen relaxer rangehen würden, dann wäre die Wikipedia für Mehrleute ein Mehrwert. Und dann würden noch mehr Leute mitmachen wollen.
Ok, Fefe sagt also auch, mehr Leute müssen da reinkommen. Und das geht nur, indem es irgendwie niedrigere Relevanzkriterien gibt. Was er jetzt auch als Beispiel wiedergebracht hat, ist ja dieses sozusagen, da kommt jemand, schreibt mit viel Herzblut einen Artikel und dann wird der gelöscht, weil er nicht relevant genug ist. Gibt es eigentlich nicht eine Möglichkeit, dass man sozusagen, bevor man überhaupt anfängt, Herzblut zu investieren, irgendwo die Frage zu stellen, ich möchte gerne einen Artikel zum Computerspiel Brutal Legend schreiben. Ist das relevant für euch?
Nee, es gibt immer wieder Leute, die das fragen und das ist leider vorher nicht feststellbar, weil es ist ja ein kollaboratives Projekt, das heißt du weißt nicht, wer da mitschreibt und du weißt nicht, wer noch irgendwelche Belege dafür bringt, dass es halt wirklich irgendwann mal eine Bedeutung hatte oder so. Und da kann man von vornherein, man kann natürlich bestimmte Sachen sagen, klar relevant, natürlich schreibt den Artikel irgendwie, macht ihn vor allen Dingen gut. Aber bei Sachen, die zweifelhaft sind, das vorher zu entscheiden, das kann ich mir gar nicht anmaßen, als Admin entscheide ich auch nicht, sondern das entscheiden die Benutzer. Ich lese mir die Argumente durch und stelle dann halt eben fest, in welche Richtung das hindert und entscheide sie entsprechend. Ich bin mehr ein Pegel.
Okay, dann der andere Punkt. Ich komme jetzt zur Wikipedia, bin neu und habe jetzt auch die Sendung gehört und denke so na okay, das ist anscheinend irgendwie schwierig. Wo gehe ich denn hin, damit ich sozusagen mehr, also ich habe keinen Bock irgendwie jetzt irgendwie die 3000 Relevanzkriterienseiten zu lesen. Gibt es irgendjemanden, der nicht wenden kann, der sagt hier bitte zeig mir mal, wie das geht?
Ja, wir haben das Mentorenprogramm. Also ich denke mal, wenn man Mentorenprogramm googelt, wird das wahrscheinlich auch in Deutschland Platz eins sein und da kann man sich anmelden, allerdings vorausgesetzt einen Benutzer-Account, den ich sowieso aus Datenschutzrecht, also aus Datengründen jedem raten würde, weil man seine IP braucht mehr nicht zu verraten. Also Account anlegen und dann Mentor suchen und der hilft dann weiter. Der beantwortet die dümmste Frage irgendwie.
Das ist halt so einer der Punkte, die mir immer wieder sauer aufstößt, ist, software-technisch ist irgendwie so die Wikipedia halt irgendwie so 2003 stehen geblieben. Also da ist halt irgendwie, also es gibt halt irgendwie keine also was man heutzutage aus anderen webbasierten Systemen erwarten würde, dass es halt so etwas gibt wie irgendwie Wizards, die einen an die Hand nehmen und einem sagen, ok pass auf hier, wir zoomen auch mal einen Link ein und so weiter. Das ist halt noch so ein Media-Wiki-2000-Style. Und wenn ich mir dann angucke, auf welchen Bergen Geld gerade die deutsche Wikimedia sitzt. Also die deutsche Wikimedia hat irgendwie in ihrem Rechenschaftsbericht 2008...
Sprachig, deutschsprachig, englischsprachig, ganz wichtig.
Also der Wikimedia Deutschland e.V. um mal präzise zu sein, sitzt auf einem riesigen Berg Kohle, laut ihrem letzten Rechenschaftsbericht, den sie letztes Jahr angeblich nicht ausgegeben bekommen haben. Weil die kriegen halt richtig viele Spenden rein. Und die Spenden können sie nicht nach den USA schieben, weil das geht nicht als gemeinnütziger Verein. Also betreiben sie einen Toolserver, ansonsten sitzen sie auf dem Geld. Warum wird dieses Geld nicht dazu investiert, mal die Hemmschwellen für Wikipedia zu senken, also für die Deutsche? Warum gibt es nicht mal Wizards, mit denen man Artikel anlegen für einfach, die einem sagen, wenn da Sachen kaputt sind? Warum wird nicht mal experimentiert mehr? Also in dem Sinne, dass man sagt, wir probieren einfach mal zum Beispiel so einen niedrigschwelligeren Namensraum aus, auf dem steht, hey, pass auf, die Artikel hier erfüllen keine enzyklopädische Relevanz, sondern sind einfach nur da, weil es die Leute vielleicht interessiert. Ich vermisse einfach so diesen Drive, zu sagen, hey, wir versuchen einfach mal mit der Zeit zu gehen. Stattdessen ist das mehr so ein jetzt ist da draußen dieses doofe Netz und jetzt sind sie alle sauer auf uns, was da sich so ein bisschen in den Diskussionen manifestiert.
Das mit dem Wursad habe ich nicht ganz verstanden, muss ich ehrlich zugeben.
Ich lege einen Artikel an und der sagt mir, pass auf, an den Artikel gehören Referenzen rein, an den Artikel gehören Belege rein. Hier ist ein Template für ein Bild, da möchte ich halt, wenn es ein Biologieartikel ist, einen Beleg über den Lebensraum und dergleichen Dinge mehr. Die Kategorien und Ansprüche sind ja da und die Informationen sind da.
Es gibt halt Millionen von Hilfeseiten und es ist einfach unmöglich, für 90 da reinzufinden. Also ich würde wirklich sagen, such den Mentor, alles andere macht im Moment wenig Sinn. Ich lerne jeden Tag dazu und ich hoffe auch, dass es nicht aufhört. Also jetzt in puncto Wikipedia.
Okay, wir müssen jetzt ein bisschen beeilen, weil es wird jetzt schon wieder knapp. Ich wollte noch die Frage stellen, also was Frank gerade meinte, die eine Möglichkeit, das Problem zu lesen, wäre Geld und Enthusiasmus drauf zu werfen und einfach auch mal die Technik zu verbessern. Die andere ist ja letztendlich, wird zumindest gesagt, funktioniert die Wikipedia demokratisch. Wenn sich jetzt genug Leute finden, die sagen, hey, wir wollen einfach die deutsche Wikipedia erinnern, wie geht das denn vonstatten?
Naja, das geht einfach, das ist halt ein basisdemokratisches System. Das heißt, wenn irgendjemand die Initiative hat dazu und sich ein paar Freunde vielleicht sucht, um zu sagen, hey, wir schaffen die Relevanzkriterien ab, wir machen das jetzt genau wie der Englischsprachigen, die Sachen müssen notable sein, das heißt also sie müssen würdig sein, notiert zu werden in der Wikipedia, dann startet er halt eben ein Meinungsbild und dann versammeln sich da die Leute, die sagen Pro oder Contra, also am besten viele Argumente aufbringen und dann wird das so entschieden und dann werden die gekippt und das wird das englischsprachige System übernommen. Funktioniert ganz einfach.
Okay, da müssen einfach möglichst viele Leute mitmachen. So, dann ist die Frage jetzt, was passiert denn eigentlich, wenn das alles versagt? Also da draußen im Netz gibt es genug Leute, die denken so, okay, mit der deutschen Wikipedia das funktioniert nicht, wir wollen jetzt auch nicht irgendwie das gesamte System unterwandern, das ist uns zu anstrengend, ich nehme jetzt auch nochmal Pfefe dazu. Also gibt es Alternativen sozusagen? Also kann man noch eine Wikipedia machen?
Ich fand das mit dem Verein vorhin gut, weil das machen wir nämlich schon teilweise, dass Sachen wirklich ins Vereinswiki exportiert werden, ins Unternehmenswiki exportiert werden, vor allen Dingen die Indiepedia ist auch sehr wichtig für Bands. Das funktioniert halt schon, das ist nicht so bekannt, aber das wird eigentlich schon gemacht und in den Hauptartikeln sind auch immer Links, also meistens Links zu den entsprechenden Fachpedias.
Aber die sind zum Beispiel nicht in die Suchmaschine integriert, was ein echtes Manko ist.
Ja, die Suchmaschine ist glaube ich ein bisschen sowieso, die wurde gerade überarbeitet, aber die ist immer noch nicht sehr gut.
Also ich meine, was ich erwarten würde ist, wenn ihr sagt, okay, wir splitten das ab in Fachpedias, dass die in der Suchmaschine drin sind, also wenn es jetzt zumindest irgendeine Art von...
Ja, eine bessere Vernetzung wäre sicher sinnvoll, weil das ist alles auf Einzelinitiative, also es sind halt immer einzelne Personen, die diese Wikis pflegen und es sind auch einzelne Personen, die dann halt eben in den Hauptartikeln das entsprechend verlinken und, ja, müsste man mal schauen. Das sollten halt eben auch irgendwelche gemeinnützigen Leute sein. Ich bin Privatleute, haben wir auch schon erlebt, die es einfach abschalten, das Wiki und so. Da muss man ein bisschen gucken.
Klar, es gibt ja diese, also zum einen diesen Export von Löschkandidaten, habe ich gesehen, also dass Löschkandidaten in solche Fachwikis rübergerettet werden. Aber, naja, ich meine, am Ende ist halt schon die Frage, wenn jetzt, sagen wir dir, die Enzyklopedisten bei der Deutschen Wikipedia halt bei ihrem, sagen wir mal, Meinungs- bei ihrer Meinung beharren und dann kann es halt schon passieren, dass das Netz halt, bzw. die Leute, die sagen, wir wollen eine Mehreren haben, sagt, wir machen jetzt mal eine Wikipedia Lite. Und forken halt, sagen wir, wir nehmen halt den Datenstand mit und gehen halt irgendwie, fangen halt nochmal von vorne an.
Wir haben ja seit mindestens fünf, weiß ich glaube, wenn man das allein macht, ist das überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Ja, forken, kurz erklären, man nimmt seinen aktuellen Stand und macht von da aus in eine andere Richtung weiter und sagt, okay, wir nehmen den aktuellen Datenstand und wir setzen uns ein neues Set von Riegeln und machen halt weiter.
Aber wäre es dann nicht schon wieder so, wenn man sagt, okay, wir nehmen jetzt so viele Leute, dass wir es schaffen, die gesamte Wikipedia noch mal aufzubauen und dann anders weiterzumachen, wäre es dann nicht sinnvoller, wenn die einfach zur normalen Wikipedia gehen und da mitmachen?
Naja, es ist eben die Frage, ob das geht oder nicht. Wir würden halt einfach den Datenstand, den würde man ja einfach mitnehmen. Das ist ja das Schöne an der Wikipedia, ist ja freies Wissen. Das heißt also, der Datenstand ist ja einfach weiterverwendbar. Ich meine, das ist halt eine extreme Angelegenheit und ich würde das auch nicht unbedingt als erstes irgendwie in Betracht ziehen, aber so wie ich die Entwicklung der Diskussion sehe und auch genau dieses Problem zwischen Enzyklopädie aber dann doch nicht zitierfähig, das ist so ein inhärenter Widerspruch, ob es dann nicht vielleicht auch der Wikipedia, also der jetzigen enzyklopedischen Wikipedia leichter gemacht wurde zu sagen, okay, wir verschärfen unsere Relevanzkriterien noch mal einen Tick und kommen hin zu einer zitierfähigen Brockhaus Replacement Enzyklopädie, wenn es auf der anderen Seite eine populäre Wiki-Dingsda gäbe.
Es gibt ja, also vorhin sagte ich ja der eine, Karl Inner, mit den geprüften Versionen, die es gäbe, die gibt es noch nicht, das sind die gesichteten Versionen, die geprüften Versionen, die sollen darauf eigentlich hinauslaufen, dass halt eine Person, die von dem Fach wirklich Ahnung hat, dass alles bis auf die letzte Zeile prüft und dann freigibt. Ich persönlich finde die Entwicklung eigentlich nicht gut, muss ich sagen. Aber ich schätze, dass früher oder länger, also früher oder später wird das auf uns zukommen, weil die Leute, die halt höhere Qualität wollen, die setzen sich halt auch ziemlich stark durch.
Also kann ich vielleicht noch einen...
Ja, gerne.
Genau, also ich hätte gern den Wikimedia-Leuten jetzt mal praktisch öffentlich, on the record, zitiere ich, dass den Vorschlag unterbreitet, dass sie einfach die Deletionpedia aufbauen. Weil ich meine, ihr sitzt an der Datenbank, ihr habt die Daten, ihr habt die Bandbreite, ihr habt Geld, auf dem ihr sitzt, macht einfach eine Deletionpedia. Die Software habt ihr auch, die Toolserver habt ihr. Warum soll das jemand anderes machen? Also wir haben jetzt in Deutschland, weiß nicht, was hab ich, es gibt dieses Waste-Dings irgendwas, also es gibt einen Typ, der das gemacht hat, aber der ist vielleicht am ersten Tag erschlagen worden von der Bandbreite, als ich auf den gelinkt hab. Und es gibt irgendwie diese Marjorie-Links, naja, ich mein, das ist halt nichts, was man nach ihm stemmt. Der CTC könnte das vielleicht machen, aber wollen wir das? Ich mein, eigentlich nicht. Im Grunde sitzt Wikimedia auf den Servern, die das können, auf der Software, die das kann, und sitzt auch direkt an der Datenbank und könnte sich selbst triggern, um die gelöschten Artikel einfach rüber zu puken. Und wenn wir das machen, dann haben wir quasi alle Bausteine schon zusammen, dann können ruhig die Qualifizisten in der Haupt-Wikipedia glücklich werden. Und dann haben wir im Grunde alle Vorschläge mit Minimalaufwand erschlagen. Kann auf denselben Server laufen. Also das ist meines Erachtens die billigste Lösung, die es überhaupt gibt. Und dann der Schritt zwei, was ich vor ein paar Wochen schon mal vorgeschlagen habe, aber da kann ich am Radio nochmal sagen, wäre, dass wenn du auf einen gelöschten Artikel gehst oder nach einem suchst und da gibt es einen Artikel, aber der ist gelöscht, dann steht halt nicht, gibt es nicht, sondern dann steht halt dieser Artikel, der ist gelöscht worden, weil wir ihn für, was weiß ich, unrelevant oder schlecht halten. Wenn du ihn trotzdem sehen willst, klicke hier. Weil wenn du das hättest, dann seid ihr A, also ihr Wikipedianer mit euren Qualitätsanforderungen. B würde es aber trotzdem Leuten geholfen werden, die irgendwas suchen. Also ich meine, das kann man ja alles vereinbaren.
Was man dazu sagen muss, ist, dass die englische Deletionpedia enthält keine Artikel, die beleidigend sind oder wegen Datenschutz gelöscht worden. Das ist halt ein wichtiger Punkt, um dem einmal gleich zuvor zu kommen. Sondern worum es halt geht, sind tatsächlich Artikel, die eben...
Na ja, eben, perfekt, passt doch alles. Also das ist meines Erachtens eine minimale Sache. Das kann ein Typ an einem Tag hatten.
Siehst du da irgendwie eine Chance für sowas? Ich bin nicht von Wikipedia.
Ich bin nicht mein Mitglied.
Aber innerhalb der Wikipedia...
Vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz sagen, Sargoth ist ein Admin der Wikipedia, macht das sozusagen aus freien Stücken und ehrenamtlich. Und Wikipedia, also der Verein, der sich quasi um die deutsche Wikipedia kümmert, ist nochmal eine andere Sache. Aber natürlich gehen an die die Forderungen raus, weil es gibt zwar nicht wirklich einen Schuldigen in der Wikipedia, aber es sind doch die Leute, die am ehesten die Mittel haben, wie mir scheinen will. Und die haben am 5.11. auch ein Treffen.
Genau, am 5.11. Die Räume sind noch nicht ganz klar, muss man noch mal googeln. Dann am 5.11. findet eine Diskussion statt genau über diese Themen. Wo ein paar Leute, du bist auf dem Podium?
Also ich hab mich als Nachrüber gestellt, weil ich eigentlich nicht wirklich Lust habe.
Okay. Ja, ich denke von uns werden eine Menge Leute da sein. Mal gucken. Wir diskutieren gerade eine ganze Menge Vorschläge, halt wie zum Beispiel die Legionpedia, aber halt auch eben zu sagen, okay, in einem softeren Namensraum, aber auch so Sachen, wie zum Beispiel Löschen schwieriger machen. Das brauchen wir jetzt nicht aufmachen, nicht fast, aber einfach, sagen wir mal, die Hemmschwelle für...
Na die ist schon sehr hoch. Also die Leute haben oft nach ein paar Monaten keine Lust mehr, in der Löschwelle sich zu bewegen, weil sie wirklich übel sind.
Wegen der Diskussion?
Naja, weil du wirst halt einfach übelst beschimpft, obwohl du sachlich Argumente abgebogen hast. Also das hatten wir auch glaub ich irgendwie so, der Kasus knackt, das ist halt eben, wenn es zu Beleidigungen kommt, dann verliert man häufig die Lust.
Ja klar. Also gut, ja, aber okay, es gibt da jedenfalls eine Menge Diskussionsvorschläge. Interessanterweise sind viele von denen ja auch schon innerhalb der Wikipedia gekommen. Also ich hab irgendwie ältere Blogpostings von 2007 gefunden, wo halt genau diese Relevanzdiskussion zum Beispiel schon mal aufgemacht wurde und so. Teilweise auch von Leuten, die in der Wikipedia sehr aktiv waren. Und dann stellt sich dann immer so ein bisschen der Eindruck eines ziemlichen Beharrungsvermögens ein, so als wenn sich so der Konsens sehr glacial bewegt.
Ja, so ist das halt.
Also da ist ja doch schon so ein Soziotop entstanden, ne?
Ja, es hat sich aber auch ziemlich viel verändert. Also dieses Hippieske, was so früher irgendwie so ein bisschen in der Wikipedia war, das ist halt mit dem Eingang des Mainstreams so ein bisschen weggekommen. Also die Sachen sind auch viel härter und werden halt viel verbissener gesehen. Ich glaube, es sind halt viele neue Benutzer dazugekommen, die halt eben gerne Artikel schreiben, aber mit diesem ganzen Open-Source-Umfeld oder so mit diesem freien Wissensgeschichte, mit dem, was es halt bedeutet, konsensorientiert oder mindestens kompromissorientiert zu arbeiten, sich erstmal einfinden müssen.
Und dann gibt es noch einen weiteren Termin. Die Wikipedia-Diskussion ist an dieser Stelle natürlich nicht beendet. Das ist wieder eines von diesen Themen, die kann man in zwei Stunden gerade so anreißen. Ihr könnt auf jeden Fall weiter mitmachen. Am 5.11. wie gesagt, ist diese Diskussion. Er kommt außerdem Sargoth, die kann man auf der Wikipedia auch erreichen, wenn man Fragen hat.
Ja, genau, der Benutzer-Diskussion, die ist immer offen, die wird nicht für IPs zugemacht.
Sargoth wird geschrieben dann mit TH noch am Ende.
S-A-R-G-O-T-H, genau.
Ansonsten noch kurz den Werbeblock. Wir haben wieder ein Kongress am Jahresende zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr, den Chaos Communication Kongress. Da wird es auch vermutlich ein größtes Diskussions-Podium zum Thema Wikipedia geben. Also das Thema beschäftigt uns da weiter. Ansonsten macht der Chaos Computer Club auch am 5.11. nach der Wikipedia-Diskussion noch einen Datengarten in den Räumen der Marienstraße 11 zum Thema Computerspiele am Beispiel von Stalker. Ja, Markus.
Da bin ich wohl dabei.
Da bist du wohl dabei. Gehen wir nach der Wikipedia-Diskussion hin. Ja, und ansonsten erreicht uns auch den üblichen Medien.
So sieht es aus. Diese Sendung gibt es außerdem als Podcast auf Chaosradio.de und auf Fritz.de auch. Und ich gebe hiermit ab an die beiden Irren von der Mittwochnacht. Das sind nämlich HerrSmiss und HerrSmart. Und wenn ihr die schon gehört habt, wisst ihr, die sind nicht ganz knusper. Heute wird es noch ein bisschen härter. DJ Morgoth haben sie mitgebracht. Auch so ein Mashup-Freak von Booty Berlin. Ich weiß nicht genau, was sie hier machen wollen, aber Ohrenstöpseln könnten gut sein, sonst fängt es an zu bluten. Ich verabschiede mich nochmal mit meinem Lieblingssong zu dieser Sendung. Website von Trekkie Birthday.
Tschüss.